here are five things different about the
Samsung Galaxy Z flip 5. the Z flip 5
sports a much larger 3.4 inch flex
window that is almost four times bigger
than a Z flip 4. even with a bigger Flex
window the Z flip 5 is still a compact
Queen now measuring at 15.1 millimeters
instead of the 15.9 millimeters we saw
last year you know what that means it'll
slip into the pockets of your jeans
easily the zenflip 5 has also been
upgraded with a Snapdragon 8 Gen 2
chipset matching other Flagship
smartphones in the market a new feature
we love are the flip suit cover content
cards that allows you to personalize
your case and flex window through the
use of NFC interactive cards lastly the
Ziploc 5 now comes in a new color the
also cute mint